we begin this hour with the black friday
weekend shopping frenzy about 158
million americans are expected to take
part in the rush that's nearly 2 million
more than last year according to the
national retail federation many items
have gone up in price and 78 percent of
americans say that is forcing them to
cut back on buying gifts
jeff jeannette is the ceo of macy's he
joins us from their herald square their
flagship store here in new york city
which opened to shoppers at 6 00 a.m
today good morning jeff
happy black friday dana
thank you i will be shopping later i
promise but holiday shoppers right now
are worried about a couple things
worried about increasing prices worried
about inflation right now how do you
expect this season to look
yeah so i think it's going to be strong
you know i think we're going to have a a
very strong holiday season you know we
start preparing for this as soon as we
finish the holiday season from the
previous year so we've got all the gifts
and all the brands and all the
categories
and we're ready to go this holiday both
online as well as our stores so i think
it's going to be a good holiday season
you know you mentioned that but rising
cost has some people wondering what they
can afford whether they can afford more
than before has that not had an impact
yet or you don't expect it to have an
impact
you know i don't expect it to have an
impact because we plan for it so you
know we we're when we look at all of the
customer data
we're making adjustments all the time on
where customers uh where they're more
price sensitive than in other categories
so like with commodities when you look
like a basic t-shirt or you're looking
at a gift under you know handle we're
going to be holding our prices uh and
then there's other categories
particularly in our fashion categories
or luxury categories uh we're a higher
ticket because of the make of the
product or the brand of the product
where they'll accept a higher averaging
at retail so you know we have we've gone
through these inflation cycles many
times in the past we've been working
with our overseas suppliers to get costs
down and we have lots of data and
analytics and pricing science that helps
us make decisions about the sale prices
we offer and the markdowns that we take
in an item in a store level so we're
ready for whatever inflation is out
there
jeff let me correct myself before we go
any further gannett i said your last
name incorrectly and i i apologize for
that
um you didn't open yesterday on
thanksgiving and i know a lot of places
were open do you expect that to be the
industry standard going forward you know
it's a great question i will tell you
that it's a kind of a it's a polarizing
topic uh you know you've got a lot of
customers that want us to be open on
thanksgiving and you've got other
customers that don't so what i will say
is that we're open online and so the
bulk or a big chunk of our business is
digital and so both the bloomingdales
and blue mercury and the macy's brands
customers can get great values all the
way through thanksgiving online we did
open you know at 6am as you mentioned
dana at the top and uh it was good
traffic versus 2020 coming in the first
couple of hours we just got the eight
o'clock flashes and we're in pretty good
shape so uh store business is starting
out brisk online shopping is very strong
as i mentioned i think holiday shopping
is going to be great this year
uh so jeff as you know the retail sector
is struggling to fill openings and
macy's was looking to hire thousands of
holiday workers quick fun fact my very
first job in 1985 at the nanuet mall
macy's was as a holiday worker i was in
high school so i have fond memories what
incentives are you offering to get young
people or other to come and work for you
all right vlad i'm going to put your
picture up in the hall of fame
just so you know that's coming that's
coming our way finally employee of the
month i'm looking forward
[Applause]
so um you know look this was something
that um when you look at you know our
colleagues they're our biggest asset and
so making sure that uh that they have
all the incentives that they need to for
us to be able to acquire colleagues and
to retain the great ones that we have
very top of mind for us so obviously
what you've seen over time is that you
know wages are going up and we did that
early in supply chain early in the third
quarter because that could be a big
bottleneck if you don't get supply chain
right so we got all of our hiring done
well in advance we're in great shape
there and you heard us make our
announcement uh right before our
earnings call to raise you know our
average minimum wage to 15 we're going
to have that fully employed by may of
22. we have it in a number of stores
right now where we it was the most
stubborn hiring rates we're in great
shape so i'm looking at my customer
service scores go up every day you know
they're loving customers are loving what
they see in our stores uh so you know i
know we're going to be competitive with
with all of our and having the right
employee proposition to get great
colleagues
jeff i love how you call employees your
colleagues but i want to talk about uh
the biden administration's new push
actual mandate
that big companies like yours get their
employees
flash colleagues
vaccinated and
weekly testing how are you reacting to
that
yeah so we're very supportive of of of
this uh but the timing of it is
problematic for us so when this came out
from osha in november you know to have
this completely implemented and done by
january as problematic for national
retailers so we support it the timing is
a problem for us
all right jeff gadnett happy holidays
thank you very much appreciate it
thank you